a newly released video shows a northern
california mother who claimed she had
been kidnapped confronted with the proof
that she made the whole thing up
sheri papini is her name she was
sentenced on monday to 18 months in
prison for her kidnapping hoax
the interrogation video shows mapini
breaking down as detectives show her the
evidence that she lied to them nikki
batis has the story
faced with dna evidence photographs and
statements by her accomplice and
ex-boyfriend sherry papini's kidnapping
hoax crumbled when interrogated by two
shasta county sheriff's office
detectives in august of 2020. when we
talk to him confront him with the dna
and tell us what happened the video
released tuesday shows papini
accompanied by her husband sobbing at
times when confronted by police over the
false claims that she was kidnapped in
2016 by two hispanic women whom she says
beat her when in fact she with the help
of her ex-boyfriend james reyes
inflicted the injuries on herself
the reason why your nose got broke is
because you held the hockey stick to
your face and he forced it into your
nose for three weeks papini's
disappearance sparked a media firestorm
and a massive community search when she
was found she spoke of being tortured
and branded parts that don't make sense
are that you're accusing two females
who abducted you when it was james
the part that you were branded
james did
he told me you know i feel like you know
my whole world is gonna flip upside down
again keith papini stood by his wife's
side prior to the interrogation
after her sentencing monday he said my
current focus is on moving on and doing
everything i can to provide my two
children with as normal healthy and
happy of a life as possible for cbs
mornings i'm nikki batiste
like something out of a movie that story
was so upsetting imagine what it did to
the hispanic community yeah they were
put under the gun her husband by the way
filed for divorce two days after she
after she pled guilty yeah rooting for
him and the kids that he's now raising
of course